but first we start tonight again at the
border where the biden administration
finally today allowed after being
pressured
the media they allowed them some access
to one migrant holding facility
i'm sure it was after it was cleaned up
and as you can see the images
as we've been showing you because we
sneak out these images
they didn't want these images out the
donna texas facility which is equipped
to hold
only 250 people and only for a short
period of time
it is now filled with over four thousand
migrants illegal immigrants that means
it is operating
at sixteen hundred percent capacity that
means
as you can see there is no room for
social distancing
no room for proper hygiene no room for
cova testing
the facilities are already overwhelmed
they don't have enough people to take
care of the people that are there
and as we speak there are more than
eighteen thousand migrant children
currently in cbp custody this is an
all-time
high hundreds of thousands of migrants
are now expected to cross
by july likely over a million we thought
well i thought we were in the middle of
a pandemic i thought dr
fauci the great dr fauci and the
hysterical
fearful cdc director they told us they
were worried about covert 19.
joe biden keeps yelling at you about
wearing your mask and distancing
joe biden is calling for more draconian
shutdowns
so where is joe biden where is anthony
fauci where is the cdc's director
concerned
at these images at these jam-packed
migrant facilities
with people literally stacked on top of
one another
in cages joe's cages he built those
cages
if this is not a super spreader event dr
fauci
one must ask what is do you even care
why the silence from the great trump
hating dr fauci
at this important moment what happened
to follow the science
and facilities that are so overcrowded
many of these migrants including those
potentially infected
we have high rates of covert positivity
are just being released
and into cities they're being sent to
cities all across the country take a
look at this footage from senator
lankford
and his recent border tour take a look
they can have like 10 people together
that all say their family
and if they have one child that's five
or six years old
then all these folks will be released
tonight into mcallen texas this is the
problem
this is one of the areas that the media
is not allowed to be able to come into
that's why i wanted to be able to be
here
to be able to see it and say this is the
thing that biden does not want you to
see
is that literally people walk across the
border they check in here
and they are all released 100 of the
people that are here tonight will be
released
so this is absolutely an open border
situation
anyone who wants to come in from any
country in the world
where do you see the tape that ted cruz
is giving us exclusively tonight that he
put together
wow because remember they wanted all the
senators to delete their phones
the gag order on border patrol agents
they're not allowed to do interviews
ride alongs
those interviews must go through the
biden white house and tonight the border
right now we are facing not only a
national security crisis
but a health crisis and a humanitarian
crisis on top of
all of it and with cbp agents now forced
to care for thousands of children
by the way many of them have not been
vaccinated themselves
and processed and processed thousands
and thousands of adults and children
our borders are less secure and don't
think the cartels and the human
traffickers and the drug dealers
and the gangs are not taking advantage
they're taking full advantage
knowing the attention of border patrol
is elsewhere
according to an investigation project
veritas releasing today
cbp encounters with registered sex
offenders
is now at a five-year high 214
encounters
with sex offenders in just the last few
months in other words
trying to get into our country and
meanwhile dangerous cartels
human traffickers capitalizing as we
speak on
all of this one coyote bragging to
univision that he was making a great
living
smuggling illegal immigrants across the
rio grande
and that biden's benefits gave migrants
the courage to make the journey to the
u.s
a nine-year-old migrant a little girl
just drowned trying to cross the rio
grande
unaccompanied migrants are being
sexually assaulted during their perilous
journey
the vast majority of migrants men women
children
experience some kind of violence during
this arduous journey through mexico
is that what compassion looks like in
joe biden's america
because remember biden told the migrants
yeah if you're
looking for asylum come he promised to
welcome them
with open arms is this open arms he
vowed to expand
asylum visas for migrants he ended
trump's stay in mexico policy
ended border wall construction he put
back in place
oh yeah catch and release and now biden
is completely unprepared in fact it's
not even clear
frankly that joe biden even recognizes
the depth of the problem that he has now
created at our southern border
because last week he just delegated his
border responsibilities
just like talking to foreign leader
responsibilities to his vice president
maybe we should start practicing or
president harris
and i think we all know why joe biden is
obviously not doing that well it seems
weak frail and we all know he's
struggling cognitively
to prove it yesterday once again he
could barely string words together
during a brief public appearance take a
look
this week alone there are more doors
there are more doses of vaccine
available for seniors this week
than any week thus far second
i'm reiterating my call for every
governor mayor and local leader
to maintain and reinstate the mass
mandate
please this is not politics
reinstate the mandate if you let it down
the failure to take this virus seriously
precisely what got us in this mess in
the first place
risk more cases more desks deaths
hey joe it's not politics get the kids
on top of each other out of your cages
and while joe is trying hard to figure
out the difference between the word desk
and the word
death his vice president is supposed to
according to him
be in charge of the crisis at the border
but in reality
she's not doing anything at all as a
matter of fact she still has no plans to
visit nor does joe
she has zero immigration meetings on her
schedule
we checked not one nothing at all
instead she is laughing hysterically at
parents they're struggling with
child care during this year's widespread
school
shutdown she thinks it's funny look for
yourself
yeah affordable child care is a big deal
more parents are seeing the value of
educators when they had to
bring their kids
and said we're not paying them nearly
enough
what's so funny kamala really is what's
happening at the border funny to you too
what's funny about americans trying to
work
trying to get their kids a good
education which many blue state
governors as a matter of side note are
failing at
we spend more per capita than any
industrialized country with the worst
results
and keeping kids home during an ongoing
pandemic
now when the kids leave joe's cages
guess what we now know they're being
sent
all over the country and if you're a
child migrant fortunate enough to
actually leave
biden's cages you're immediately granted
in-person learning
in california and san diego even though
many california students except if
you're gavin newson's kids in a private
school
you've been out of a classroom for over
a year 130
000 alone in the san diego union
district
just that one district in san diego
according to a shocking fox news report
teachers from san diego's unified school
district are teaching
migrant children in person before their
own students who haven't been there for
a year
san diego county supervisor jim desmond
told fox news
it's great that there's in-person
learning for those
unaccompanied minors from central
america that are
in the country illegally but i wish
every child in san diego county was
allowed the same opportunity
for in-person teaching have we really
lost our minds remember
you the american people you are paying
for all of this
just like you're paying every one of
these illegal immigrants we expect over
2 million this year you will pay for
their housing
you will pay for their food you will pay
for their health care shelter you name
it you'll pay for it all
and think about that when you try to
balance your you know checkbook at home
and pay your bills and pay your taxes or
your rent or your mortgage or your car
or your truck payment
but of course circle back jenn saki
couldn't seem to care less take a look
does the white house think that this
sends the right message to these
130 000 kids in san diego and their
parents who've been
stuck at home the last year well i'm
just saying that context is important
and these kids are going back to school
for hybrid learning we of course want
that to be five days a week and we're
confident we'll get there
early next month and i believe they're
also on spring break right now so these
teachers are would be
i'm not sure if it's volunteer or paid
you'd have to ask the local school
district
um while the kids are on spring break
which i think the context is pretty
important
context hey circle back take a look they
haven't been in the classroom
in over a year not one that one day
make no mistake the biden administration
does not have compassion
for we you the american people or your
children
and frankly they're not even showing
compassion for the migrants that they
claim to have a monopoly of compassion
on
they're not transparent they're covering
up they are putting a gag on
order on agents and they don't seem to
give a rip about unity on top of it all
for them it's about power here with more
we welcome her now to the fox news
family it's great to have her she's been
a friend of this program for a long time
fox news contributor laura trump uh i've
been here 25 years
congratulations this is a great place
we're honored to have you thank you for
being with us
oh well i'm so excited john thank you so
much i'm so happy to be part of the fox
family officially
it seems like a long time coming i've
always joked that i've been an
unofficial part so thank you for having
me
you know as a special gift i might not
ask you if you're going to run for north
carolina senate just
as an opening opening gift because i
have been asking a lot
all right now on a serious note these
kids haven't been in school for a year
you see these kids in cages now they
tried to
blame your father-in-law in 2018 for the
kids in cages
the video they showed was from biden and
obama years because biden and obama
built those cages
and now they built the new cages now
they're not even testing these kids
they're all sleeping on top of each
other
but we're getting lectures about the
need to wear our mask socially distanced
and shut down
now i would think if they really cared
about this issue
uh they wouldn't allow this disaster to
be unfolding before
our eyes and wouldn't be trying so hard
to cover it up
yeah well they don't care they care
about one thing and that is
power they stopped prioritizing the
american people a long time ago in case
nobody noticed
the day that joe biden took office he
eliminated 11
000 energy jobs right off the bat the
fact that these kids to your point
it's been over a year since so many of
them have been in school
parents are struggling to our vice
president kamala harris
the parents are having a really hard
time because they are having to figure
out
what do i do with my kid do i go to work
or do i stay home and try and teach my
kid remotely which is
nearly impossible yet we are paying now
86 million dollars of taxpayer money
sean
to put people who have come to our
country illegally
broken our laws in hotel rooms it is so
outrageous and now
the migrant kids get to go to school i
mean i don't understand
what is going on with these folks on the
left again they stopped prioritizing
americans a long time ago
nothing could be clearer but i think
it's really upsetting the hypocrisy
and and you make a great point because i
think when donald trump was in office
look
we we saw the way that they it could you
imagine for a second if donald trump was
in charge of any of this
he was so transparent he always answered
questions of the media
he let everybody in to see the
facilities that yes
joe biden and barack obama built it's so
upsetting and frustrating i think to so
many people
to see what has gone on here but it's no
surprise under joe biden could you
imagine
if these new cages and there actually
are henry cuellar put out pictures of
kids in
cages then you got the plastic cages
then you got the for the little kids the
other plastic cages and there's no
social distancing they're all on top of
each other we're in the middle of the
pandemic
we're putting our border patrol agents
when you really look at the policies of
donald trump saying we will not let you
in you will stay in mexico he is
building the wall
and we got rid of catch and release now
what did that result in people did not
make this perilous
journey into what is frankly
uh the biggest super spreader event i
think the world has seen
now unfolding before our eyes
yeah and not only that but you know
around a quarter of the women
that make this track up through mexico
into our southern border
are sexually assaulted these young girls
are sexually assaulted they're sold into
child slavery they're sold into sex
trafficking
it is absolutely abominable the best
thing possible
is to never have anyone make that
journey under president donald trump
he made it very clear they were not
going to try and do it because they knew
they would be sent home
the president of mexico sean calls joe
biden the migrant
president because he is allowing all of
these people just to flow into america
it is a joke
we look ridiculous it is a security
issue
if we allow this to continue we are
going to lose
america as we have always known it it is
a terrifying thing to see
but we don't expect anything to change
because joe biden's not going to the
southern border kamala harris is not
going to the southern border you know
who probably is going to the southern
border
president donald j trump because the
border patrol want him down there they
finally felt like they had an
ally when president trump was in office
and you know what he
he says he's probably going to go down
there and visit the southern border
they want some kind of support they
can't get it from this administration
they will get it from president donald
trump
uh we're going to have tape that senator
ted cruz is giving us
exclusively tonight laura and all
honestly uh you've always been gracious
with your time
always coming on the program we're glad
you're part of our fox family thank you
for being with us
and welcome many years to come
thank you excited to be part of the team